watching game Bush's campaigning against
Poland's shift to the right he and other
like-minded people from the Jets nuh are
planning to join a demonstration in
Warsaw the Law and Justice Party has
been in power for four months and is
already ushered in a slate of
controversial reforms the opposition is
worried about democracy and human rights
Jem bush lives in purchase now where
many are too afraid to join the
opposition he's organizing the trip to
Warsaw with mixed success
gimm bush spends all his spare time
trying to drum up support for the
opposition movement hello there may I
come in door stopping isn't usually his
thing he's an IT expert but what's
happening in his country is made him
politically active for the first time in
his life he wants the government to know
that the opposition is alive and well
but is it would you like to join a
demonstration to Warsaw no it's on
saturday as i'm using the return ticket
costs 80 swathi tickets are still
available would be beautiful be feeling
no luck but at least they sign his
petition at the same time you're put off
our democracy must be defended and
nurtured Nick to the road yet again not
many people I'll express a political
opinion as openly as this couple just
did especially not on camera most are
afraid of what the neighbors will say no
one wants to say what they think oh poor
God dodge a peek at the double hating on
you vallejo it's not a goblin anyone in
this country who opposes the government
is immediately denounced as a communist
or the Gestapo poniard onion bhaji
comunista or accused of having had a
grandfather in the ver marked a top star
game Bush lives in Bachchan in
south-eastern poland
every second person here voted for the
law and justice party with the movement
let's see who else could i get to sign a
petition to me Emeli stone there are the
benjamins vonage the opposition needs
100,000 signatures before a referendum
on reversing the government's reforms
can be requested LeBron okay lover great
thanks anyway inba chester only 50
people who designed so far he's not
interested so peaceful in years ago Gina
Daria knows when you were at least
marching is not the only one in Pichette
sure collecting signatures for the
petition he's arranged to meet another
campaigner here in the parking lot don't
think they were dealing with contraband
not a perfectly legal petition
the local chapter of the committee for
the protection of democracy is also
cagey about its activities with the last
two months government critics have been
holding meetings to discuss the
situation along with marching seven
people have gathered here today
cartagena Blish niak is planning to take
part in the demonstration in warsaw it
wasn't an easy decision for her to make
her husband was among those who voted
for the Law and Justice Party my name
posted good see
this government wasted no time altering
the Constitution in my opinion were
headed for a dictatorial regime an
autocratic state a police state this is
a manipulative government who knows what
else it's planning if you stay I feel I
have to do something was that Yellen so
she is the group has raised money for a
banner they'll take with them on the
demonstration it arrives the next day Oh
God let's have a look it's great it's a
[ __ ] whoa beata she drew the polish
Prime Minister she used to be mayor of a
sister random gauges people will know
her from here many people are outraged
by the local anti-government movement to
my natural entails venient on a
particular yamaha did you watch eva
specifically on the next day ma chingam
bush and his fellow protesters set off
for the demonstration in Warsaw there
are just four of them
live in theory i hope there are lots of
demonstrators in warsaw and then
everyone who didn't go wishes they had
glad to go at the Machine impossible
other anti-government protesters from
the southeast of Poland are already on
board in the last few weeks the group
has been organizing the trip on facebook
the committee for the protection of
democracy now has chapters all over the
country the journey will take about five
hours k summation is for me we're going
to get off to greet the people boarding
the train in Katowice it'll be like a
rehearsal for the demonstration will go
down onto the platform through that door
there and shout freedom diversity
democracy and then join the democracy
train bojong watching the democrats
worsening let me say this on camera
Shimon organized the demonstrations in
BL scope yawa a great guy I've known him
a week right it's only a week I heard
the speech too there aren't many people
as young as shamone on the committee for
the protection of democracy isn't it a
little cramped in here hey des go to Law
and Justice Party attracted a lot of
support from the under-30s in the last
election the passengers discuss why that
was
not enough history's taught in schools
youngsters don't even know that massive
v8 ski was the first polish Prime
Minister after communism people expect
simple solutions they just want someone
who'll look after them a [ __ ]
identified hit the Derby event your
doctor to make it somewhat absurd they
want to Putin finger a dictator who
tells them what to do Bogut some young
people have never lived to a
dictatorship they have a very
black-and-white view of the world they
don't believe in gray areas the train
pulls in to Katowice bow joke no
Democrat see
they'll be reaching Warsaw in about
three hours marching is getting ready
for the demonstration giving himself a
liquid awesome moustache as a tribute to
the famous activist who led solid on
hush [ __ ] [ __ ] I've never painted my
face but there's always a first time the
government is accused Poland's national
hero of having collaborated with the
secret police in the Communist era for
us Lewenza is a symbol of Poland's
liberation the current government is
deliberately trying to damage his
reputation and undermine the role he
played in Polish history you funny I do
suddenly the train grinds to a halt it
doesn't move for the next two hours
there's a technical problem it looks
like the passengers won't make the
demonstration in Warsaw
the moisture tovarich italy by the time
the train sets off again Martinez
worried they'll have missed everything
the train finally arrives in Warsaw yeah
we're heading off to meet the
demonstration it's in this direction the
train was two hours late we missed the
start something up or thumbs they left
from behind the National Stadium Bambi
that you start download over 20 minutes
later they catch up with the others
demonstrators from the Prime Minister's
hometown that's quite a statement the
10,000 protesters wind their way through
the city sorry that machine alabanza I
just system as frisky but difficult your
mama thinks when it's finished ma
chainsets about collecting more
signatures for his petition he manages
to get nearly 250 that [ __ ] better for
them I gotta release day
she is going to enough young team that
won't have been our last demonstration
we need to get even more people out on
the streets a hundred thousand one
hundred and twenty thousand a hundred
and fifty thousand he and his friends
will take the train back to persist shed
the same evening re-energized for their
fight
you